all right we did it we watch spider-man
homecoming people okay but before we hop
into our movie review for spider-man
homecoming we wanted to give a quick
shout out to today's video sponsor amino
apps you may remember amino from back
when we talked about the final fantasy
amino and today in honor of spider-man
homecoming we're going to be talking
about the new and improved Marvel amino
the Marvel amino allows you to share
your fandom with Marvel fans from across
the world and thanks to the apps newly
designed interface there are more way to
engage than ever the Marvel amino offers
the same great message board experience
along with a brand new news feed and
even more customizable layouts and
features allowing you to make your amino
truly your own you can chat with friends
share your art gifts and videos post
blogs and polls ask questions and your
challenges and you can take advantage of
the newest features by creating your own
quizzes competing on the leaderboards
sharing your moods and check-ins and
more us we're movie buffs we discuss a
lot of Marvel films so we've been having
fun with the polling question features
you can find this on the Marvel amino as
the real rejects all one word hop on
there take a look at some of our
questions let us know who your favorite
on-screen spiderman villain has been so
far or which villain you're dying to see
Spidey go up against in the future you
can download the Marvel amino for
Android iPhone using the links in the
description box down below and without
further ado let's get to that review
I decided to put on the sweater because
I could finally fit into it you know
rock bolt the spider-man attire I have
in one video and I decided to stay too
hot
spider-man homecoming Biderman so this
story takes place just a couple of
months after the events of Civil War
Peter Parker is now back at home you do
want nothing more than to just be an
Avenger
yeah just pining over that hate those
training wheels up and get to the big
show but Tony Stark not just yet no no
no the plot of it really kicks off into
Peter Parker trying to find a way where
he can prove himself worthy enough to
truly be an Avenger and the way to do
that is to go after the vulture though
nobody elder seems to be too concerned
about this yeah here's a little start by
saying after watching this movie and if
you if you've seen some of our reactions
I felt like I got pretty good at
predicting how the beats of the plot
would work not exactly how the movie
would exactly be told but a lot of the
way that trick the trailers did reveal a
little too much for someone like me who
washes the truth it did play out almost
beat for beat in like the main act 1
beats
act 2 act 3 beats like how I thought it
would be but the movie is more than just
that what makes it so really great and
special is the details of the way every
one of the scenes are executed the
little nuance is the wrapped it was like
you know that I've forgotten most of the
stuff I saw from the you are lucky the
plot points aren't necessarily
revolutionary I kind of feel the same
way about Wonder Woman whereas like yeah
there are some things that are pretty
consistent with super or formula in the
plot but it's in the nuances and the
tone and the young tales and that is a
chow yeah style it's the life they imbue
it with because the end if there are
plot points you're expecting for me they
almost never looked like I was expecting
or unfolded the way I'm expecting even
though the story's headed in that
direction different things were
happening that I was expecting yeah
exactly what I really appreciate about
this I think we're in a day and age
where a lot of directors say here's the
fun I want to make and then you see it
and you're like mommy yeah I think what
she is set out to do and here but you
know before
tell me even began with her director
John Watson peeping at Marvel's saying
they wanted this film to be a real high
school movie of Peter Parker trying to
balance his high school life and be
spider-man at the same time I was really
surprised by just how well this film did
that it really is feel like the tone of
it is strongly highschool inspired and
some art of the fun of it that's part of
what makes it so enticing I know amazing
spider-man they said that's what they
wanted to do and boarded a can that
pretty fast I feel like that this one
has easily the best balance of Peters
life filled like a whole thing in the
yabbies like it's high school life and
that's happening while superhero life is
also have yeah that makes for a really
nice tone because I think also if you go
look at the vulture side of the scale
he's in like a heist movie just like a
heightened heist Mia and they both join
on the sci-fi level that the superhero
story is in that's what I found
interesting about it because I you know
that one thing the trailers did a good
job of not revealing to you is how the
vulture is really handled in this way
yeah ma'am Adrian tomes Michael Keaton
has Adrian towns tunes as he told this
home I think it is a spelling big
micropenis Adrian Toomes
what was so fascinating to me about this
movie is he's treated more like them in
the main supporting character the main
second plot as opposed to the villain
did you see in just the villain just the
antagonist cuz he's so much more than
that I'm so much more later I'm happy
that like first spider-man film in the
MCU this is easily one of the best
villains they've ever gotten definitely
one of the I think this one will
definitely be memorable because that's
the thing is I was I was really happy
that they didn't just use him to show up
and remind you that he's bad and we have
stopped him they actually spent time
showing you at least a little bit about
what this guy's motivation is what his
life is like what are you doing to
actually completely get where he's come
back from yeah yeah in a relatable way
for the average American at least at
every turn with that character they he
feels like a human being
he deals like an actual guy yeah and the
trailer is they took moments that made
it look like always chew it up this high
rate Marvel villain again
it makes the trailers made a look that
way but no he was a really nice surprise
is a very three-dimensional human
character and it's not the same humanity
sucks and either isn't bowing to me or
doesn't deserve to live I'm going to
wipe them all out yeah he's not just
this plain sinister evil dude Michael
Keaton did a really really favorable job
and his old crew like him and his crew I
thought they had a really good dynamic
to get on everything you got the sense
for their their world in their operation
which I thought was great it's really a
Peter Parker film yeah and Tom Holland
before we go into like what makes this
Peter Parker so great in this the
biggest reason to Tom Holland oh yeah
yeah yeah he brings a whole lot to Peter
Parker and he puts his own stamp on it
for sure like oh yeah there's a very
distinct difference to me
I don't want to rank these movies right
now like which is the best spider-man I
don't want to do that that's not time at
each time you gotta let impact settle in
and see how I feel how I feel over time
years even maybe he's Tom Holland was
absolutely fantastic and he makes this
film really what it is I feel yeah he is
the heart of this movie he or she
already carries this whole film yeah
he's funny he's charming he has an
awkwardness about it he's anxious at the
singles are really sincere he's super
sincere that's like the best word to
describe he's super sincere the entire
time I knew he did a great job in civil
war but seeing him as a whole character
it got me excited to see him again it
was one of the rare Marvel films where
I'm like I can't wait to see Tom
Hollands Peter Parker again well I am
one of the best ways to do that is the
way they kick off this movie by showing
you Peters perspective on the Civil War
events and as stuff you can see online
but that right off the bat sort of shows
you like oh yeah this is very much a
Peter Parker movie in Peter Berger's
world
wait afferent you know yeah because in
this movie he's his 15 year old high
school kid who really wants to be an
adult and that's in a hurry what Evan
it's so relatable because what high
school kid usually doesn't feel that way
yeah what high school kids like I'm just
a kid I don't care you know most high
school kids that I've met and even
I wasn't that at that age you just
wanted to be an adult already just want
to be treated like an adult
it's not even Kate her kid yeah you get
sick of that that movie really captures
that spirit because it does such a great
job of showing like what his status at
is in school he's known as this really
smart dude he's on the academic
decathlon team and people in the
decathlon team really think he's the
smartest guy in the group so he has a
very specific high school life he's got
his single the single mom or single on
me
yeah yeah Rousset over you guys think a
lot May there and then he has a
spider-man life but what the film does
such a magical job at doing is this film
is so heavy on its toning consequences
yeah that the consequences are not
exactly danger yeah but the idea of
being in this kid's shoes you can easily
figure out and understand what he is
feeling when he has to deal it was like
lies and has to deal with balancing this
out or even social anxiety issues like
going to a high school party is somehow
it's also well done one of all the
spider-man movies I feel like this one
has the best balance for me of actually
having stakes in the life of Peter
Parker because like yeah story that's
unfolding in the background it's like
trouble kind of follows him through high
school and I didn't even realize this
till now but he is the the really smart
kid who to everybody around is getting
into trouble on having trouble applying
himself he's that he's that guy in high
school that we've all known except he's
got a much different hobby yeah you know
and it feels like what a high schooler
would do if given you know this but yeah
yeah powers and that's integral to what
the arc of the whole movie is in what
Peter Parker has to go out you know and
you brought up that point about it being
an origin tale not yeah here Uncle Ben
just died origin exciting the powers
origin tale yeah it's not the origin
tale of him gained the powers and him
becoming spider-man this this is really
in some ways it does feel like an origin
tale of him learning how to be
spider-man and what role he should serve
as spider-man which is great too in
terms of him being an MCU addition
because they're also learning what his
role is in the MCU now yeah it's very
much aware this is in the Avenger
universe the film is very much let let
that be known but it also feels like a
smaller story within the Avengers world
and then I mean there is crossover stuff
but even to me and I usually get
frustrated by that but I thought it with
all the right size and it was all
appropriately at least off to the side
they never took over the movie and the
thing is I think it's a great point
about the origin stories yeah it's about
him becoming a mature person and also
learning about what the stakes really
are because when the movie starts down
and the scenes from sabor he's having a
great time and this movie is sort of
about how not great of a time it can be
if you're not being smart about it you
know so this is a pretty sophisticated
lesson for the airtime we're doing that
if you think about what a high school
kid would already worried about you
think about what a high school kid the
social situations the living up to
academia situations you would already
have on his plate and the weight it
would play like you watch this those
good high school movies you see them get
into a situation like oh that's bad you
feel that but a little bit but a lot
worse because you know it's like oh he
has to be spider-man - yeah your burger
is not a sad life in there because does
he get the inspire man who keeps getting
away man having a bird he's hard and
I've talked about being a high school
movie he doesn't do the amazing
spider-man route of the two-door teen in
high school it makes this his destiny
and I tied into his father it's a really
funny film easily the funniest
spider-man of them all and it's arguably
the most fun throughout without getting
too into yeah yeah without comparing too
much to prior spider-man films because
it's not on the epic scale that I felt
Sam Raimi's films were the ones he made
in spider-man's were trying to achieve
the whole tone of it was fun like a
comedy was probably one of the back John
Rizzo of Marvel films kind of art with
their screenplays and even more
naturally most of the time than and yeah
you know because these characters are
funny like there's other characters here
that are really good I really enjoyed
Ned Jacob battle on I've had friends
like that is the test actually gorgeous
you know they're super nerdy
they're the overweight one I bet you the
big they're like a big one yeah but
they're lovable and sweet
is a funny random [ __ ] I really enjoyed
his perform he's not exactly like multi
later but he's a great character who
asked questions to Peter Parker that you
would probably ask if you found out your
best friend was fired yeah yeah yeah
treats him in a way that it's like yeah
that's how I would probably treat my
friend of NIU Sneiderman yeah Judy
Vantage's yeah he is such a great as an
effortless bunny that was one of those
natural relationships I think in this
movies they really do just feel like but
yeah and it's a real joy when they're
on-screen together and the movie takes
time for all that like movie takes time
to allow people to just spend time with
each other because even I was noticing
the scene that made - it's like most of
those scenes are just what their life is
like I would have liked a little bit
more on atmae to be on through that
there was something that was kind of
missing for me there I'm like okay got
Marisa Tomei in here she's young hot MA
and as jungles
yes she's like really having to worry
like you know and the film's not an ACME
movie and the film's already 2 hours and
13 minutes I get if you felt like you
have to maybe cut out some anime stuff
you wanted to explore it really use
maybe one scene where she really
empowers him yeah or she gets a big mug
and you get like a really definitive
version of what makes this a maze so
specifically different it's like yeah
another jobs to worry about Peter let
the MAA roll were develop eaters going
through and the dynamics interaction
play out different than any other
spider-man film but there was something
missing for me I feel like she got to
fully put our stamp on it
I thought all of her scenes were good I
like that yeah I like the smaller
moments we got with them because Peters
not home I thought she could have used
the movie could have done her a solid by
giving her one great scene yeah and the
day is in this movie and there's a lot
of talk about her a lot everyone know
she was announced to being in plays his
character named Michelle and she's not
really in the movie there's like hype
surrounding yeah they're huge yeah yeah
since I was good and I she's good yeah
she has good she's like Daria yeah she's
a funny she's like the basket case kind
of yeah yeah a little bit yeah you know
the girl who acts like she doesn't care
but does the a girl acts like she
doesn't belong but you want to fit in
yes usually deadpans get sarcastic wit
at beretta challenge yeah money money
weirdly you don't really get a lot of
things with her beer burner I thought
she was going to be like the manager
yeah and this is wholly different woman
for that day yeah care of a different
carrot man who wins who does a really
good job with it oh yeah all the kids do
a great job they all felt like a real
kid they felt like real - Tom owns like
21 or something and he felt like a real
kid one of the best touches of this film
I love are like the fun and game section
when it just kind of feels semi spoof of
spider-man like it's pretty self-aware
of things that we've wondered about
spider-man and does a film takes time to
acknowledge you to make fun of it I mean
the owner Marvel takes a really good
advantage out of people learn and some
of the fun and games involves spider-man
learning about his abilities in a way we
haven't seen on the floor and those are
fun because he's still a kid trying to
get the hang of it yeah and that creates
a lot of humor because it's everybody
looks a little silly the first time they
try something yeah they're seeing where
it first puts on his suit is pretty it's
funny and how they and how they do it I
was like how does he get changed when
he's I just have to do it right after
school but he can't go home and change
how does he shoot a web what does he do
with the webs if he hasn't were to swing
you know yeah yeah after school sports
practice day yeah and had a handle
chasing down a car properly and all
these yeah so it's really about him
learning how to be spider-man and that's
that's part of the big joy of this film
I guess the best way to really summarize
what makes this spider-man so unique and
so essential and arguably the best
spider-man can't portrayal in terms of
maybe not the whole movie I feel like a
lot of people might be able to get on
board with the best spider-man portrayal
you know the quoted spider-man your
friendly neighborhood spider-man and
this movie really does feel like that it
feels like your friendly neighborhood
spider-man
they have scenes that once is a big
scene that's a straight-out tribute to
Ferris Bueller's Day Off that an actual
neighborhood in an actual neighbor like
oh yeah I got the older neighborhoods
you know because you think
in the previous spider-man movies you
mostly just see him in the city or an
industrial party on and this is like
yeah you do see that but you also see
upstate you also see neighborhoods you
also see Peters under overpass yeah like
you get a lot of geography and that
helps you know and also the scale of the
crime - absolutely we haven't talked
about any of these actually with but the
action sequences are there good there
was no action scene in this movie I
guess that's probably what the letdown
was and it sucks because it's only from
preconceived notion and prior viewing to
former spider-man movies I didn't ever
once think the action was like there's
like me ceasefire my to inspire myself
it looks cool it does it always looks
cool but it doesn't ever feel like oh
yeah that action scene was something you
know and I feel like spider-man 1 has
that I feel like spider-man 2 definitely
has that this is cool set pieces this I
mean it's it's cool it's not bad I don't
find it as there's nothing that really
mesmerized me see from where I'm sitting
right now I liked the size of it I agree
with you but at the same time I like the
size of the action and part of the point
of all of the action of the Peter is
pretty good at this but he's not great
at this yet and so all the action scenes
engaged me because they felt like she's
Chicago dude this is really trying and
also in a number of them you get to see
new abilities and physical abilities
that we haven't yet seen used so those
things made them rewarding to me because
I've seen epic spider-man and we've seen
dark gritty spider-man and this one I
thought the action scenes were big
enough and and the right size for this
movie and it's tough to love about it
absolutely and the thing is if I didn't
see these other spider-man films I
probably would have just loved this [ __ ]
out of these actions it's not necessary
for this film that's what X my point
yeah it's not necessary for that so as
much so my saying as a spider-man it's
just completely not necessary to go back
awesome bananas with it yeah it's on the
scale of this spider-man and it's in his
the size of the arrow because I feel
like the epic that the harrowing battles
that we see in like spider-man 2 I feel
like those will happen later in his life
I appreciated that about this movie that
the action was on the level of this
movie and it matched and that made it
distinct to me and in that way I guess
yeah no I'll agree with that and during
the action I was always aware of the
stakes both for spider-man you know
fighting and what's going on off screen
because almost every action scene
involves him leaving life and screwing
up life to go get it you know so I was
never not aware of that and so those
enhance the action for me personally I
guess one of the last things to touch on
the usage of Tony Stark in this film now
this film is nowhere near being Iron Man
for like everyone worried about Iron Man
3.5 people thought it would be overload
Iron Man it is not it was used just
right the position his role serves in
terms of how it affects Peter Parker and
the relationship that was all very
effective and necessary to this plot I
thought it was used wonderfully even
down to the physical choice that like
Tony was almost never anywhere near him
yeah half the time the thing is though
is some of the scenes notice it was
clear that it was it cleared up into
credit because when I watched the couple
scenes especially thatthat scene where
you know you I don't want to do it away
cuz you just haven't seen the trailer
but it there's a lot specific scene
where they're talking on a ferry and I
remember watching a single watch movie
being edited like like as if he's not on
the set I just wanna tell you that shot
against a green screen but Tom Holland
is on the case but every saw the back of
it said I'm like that doesn't look like
me just like liver those lines for me Oh
was he not there yeah like what was up
and that was the only time I was
questioning the editing of the movie and
yeah when you see the credits as Tony's
double if you but it sounds like ah
blazes yeah there's at least one see
where if you look it's like every time I
catch of Tony is upward and all you see
is sky and buildings and they cut back
to Tom Holland it's like there's the set
and there's like Tony's in frame and
then like when he turns his head just
enough they cutaway up or you can tell
what it's face looks like in LA yeah
there's two specific scenes with him
where I was like that what's really
strange is noticeable somehow why
we're not a big fan of rating systems we
give consensus on things
there's my consensus Tom Hollands Peter
Parker / spider-man is the best
interpretation most well round I have
for sure whoa my consensus you do yours
after we can interrupt my Rotten
Tomatoes consensus oh is this like all
one score and that's a yes that's your
must Amazon paragraphs we're going to go
on the freakin poster I'm just going to
continue to review this whole matter and
this is the best Peter Parker spider-man
that we've ever gotten for the big
screen and my personal third favorite
record saying so it's a great film it's
a fantastic this is this is the amazing
I didn't I did a good job on this
consensus um this should be called the
amazing spread because this one is
amazing I agree this should be called
the amazing spider-man I think it's the
most well-rounded spider-man we've
gotten even like in there things I
appreciate about all of them but I think
Tom Holland is the most well-rounded
spider-man I thought it was dazzling
just to go back to a fun movie with
real-life stakes you know there was just
the right size it kind of satisfied me
in most every way I get kind of worn out
on these movies and it definitely
satisfied me now we're going to shoot a
spoiler review for this film with Andrew
from the movie source channel and he's a
huge spider-man fan he kept every 20
minutes it'll affect fellow look but
this good fun that's correct I might
ever this guy's really is that yeah yeah
some things we'll talk about in the
spoiler review that are not really shown
in the trailer some additions to the
spider-man suit that were that really
bring new life into it yeah a little
hint right there getting life into it
you know if you have seen the movie
don't worry about that and also there's
a plenty of fun Easter eggs throughout
he does have big four other characters
that will come into the spider-man
universe like they did with you know dr.
Connor and Sam Raimi trilogy yeah oh
yeah man Dylan Baker never got
there's actually a pretty good amount of
twists and reveals here yeah some that
are very effective Woody Allen specific
twist I've heard people say there's a
good twist in this film that kind of
bothers me when I hear that yeah look
I'm like well now I'm expecting a twist
and you told me what you thought it
would be when we were parked it was one
of the twists fair enough fair enough it
wasn't always like Willie twins it
wasn't me twit it was that was more of a
reveal yeah yeah but it was a twist I
that twist was hyped up for me and then
when it happened I was like oh my god
did not do that yeah no no I'm gonna do
the same to all you guys right now
passes you know have fun with that and
there's other characters in there to
touch on as well there's plenty of other
characters that we could talk about what
will say that all for this for the
review which is a lot of use emotion
maybe a lot shorter than this book not
for the review
all right guys well thanks for if you
stuck around this long really appreciate
it hey do us a favor like and share this
video subscribe to the real rejects and
click that notification bell you can
follow this guy at John hunt dot dat
John gaunt dat John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
Blum house check out our exclusive perks
are awesome rewards we got plenty of fun
goodies over at patreon so go make sure
to check it out and last one I'll leave
shake out the Marvel amino it's actually
really freaking cool yeah and actually
if you want an unadulterated stream for
our Marvel related content that's a
great place to go look for that because
we're going to start posting all our
Marvel stuff on there and now I'm going
to lounge on my sweater to do this
thumbnail